Vision we are an unusual
couple we don't have a song
or even wedding rings well we
could remedy that i do do you i do
this place i don't understand what's happening
look it's the star of the show
oh this is gonna be a gas
you'd better be ready
they'll never see it coming
so what's our plan
is this really happening you're ready
for this mr benedict i'm mr benedict
quite an impressive display
glorious
Welcome back everyone happy new year you made it
to 2021 there's a whole bunch of new Wandavision
footage because the episodes are starting
really soon there's also a bunch of good
news about marvel's plans for all the disney
plus and avengers spin-off shows this year too
we're getting way more episodes of everything
than we originally expected so i'll explain
how that's going to work because it plays into
their programming strategy this year and they
confirmed their plans for special r rated content
section of disney plus so i'll explain how that's
going to work too because that's where all the
really hardcore stuff like the deadpool content
is going to live but if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes of all the
marvel series that are going to be releasing this
year obviously there's going to be so much stuff
coming up 2021 already looking so much better than
2020 so far say goodbye to that crap year but
in the new trailer footage they start with the
very truman show looking scenes of randall park's
jimmy wu fbi character trying to break into their
alternate dimension to save scarlet witch because
at this point they still think that she's being
trapped there by some malevolent force or some
evil marvel villain notice that the hazmat suit
that he's wearing has the big sword symbol on the
back that's because even though he's technically
fbi inside the mcu most of this is all nick
fury's sword agency handling this because it's
a big avengers level problem there is a bunch of
doctor strange 2 stuff happening during this but
i don't know if there's also going to be a bunch
of nick fury samuel l jackson stuff happening
during this too because of all the sword stuff i
think a lot of the sword stuff happening during
this will just provide more context for that
spider-man far from home post-credits scene
even though if you know what sword is in the
comics you kind of knew what was up the minute
you saw him on that space station they also
dropped the teaser for that full-blown avengers
secret invasion disney plus series they're doing
with nick fury and talos's scroll character
we probably won't be seeing footage of that for at
least another year or so it's going to be a while
before they drop those episodes but obviously the
funny thing here though is that sword is trying to
save scarlet witch without realizing that she's
the one that's doing all this she's choosing to
live in the lie quote unquote rather than face
reality she creates her own reality or changes
this reality till it suits her desires then as
you probably noticed the other biggest thing about
this new footage in the trailer is them driving
into the west view suburbian town during episode 1
with the funny theme song marvel revealed that
they had the people from the frozen movies
write theme songs for all the different episodes
for the different decades of television like they
made special theme songs for each of the different
episodes that are periods specific for the decades
of sitcoms that they're parodying in the different
episodes like they said in one of the episodes
they're gonna do the legit intro from the brady
bunch the marvel version of the brady bunch but
they probably did a special brady bunch style
theme song for that part but the songs themselves
are also part of the storytelling tropes
that they're using to comment on the plot
like the lyrics of the songs themselves will
have easter eggs about what's happening to the
characters during the episodes then there's more
bewitched footage of her changing things with
the 1950s and 1960s looking special effects the
the versions of what her powers would look like
if the avengers was happening during the 1950s and
60s then she finds the modern day technology red
helicopter in color when everything's supposed
to be black and white in 1960s level technology
that's like a big pleasantville easter egg if you
ever saw that movie it has spiderman himself toby
mcguire in it with reese witherspoon but in this
context this is just an example of the house of m
reality this fictional alternate reality that
she's helped create and she's changing things
breaking down around her slowly the cracks
starting to show like all the sword agents
slowly breaking in and her trying to kick them
out like monica rambo but then you have more
footage of them putting on the magic show or the
musical number or whatever's happening during this
performance for the rest of the town they're
sitting in the middle of the street i can't
read the name of the department store behind them
because it's kind of cut off in the frame but the
names of the streets and the buildings are also
probably marvel easter eggs and easter eggs for
the real life sitcoms that they're parodying
in these episodes the funny thing about this
character is that everybody's convinced that he's
like some crazy huge marvel villain like mephisto
he's probably one of the bigger recurring
characters because he does show up in a number of
different scenes in different decades but remember
especially at the beginning the series is all
about scarlet witch kind of deluding herself into
thinking that this is all okay and totally real
it's totally normal for me to create a fictional
reality for myself i think if anyone in this
reality is actually messing with her it's act
of the harknesses character here there's also
more footage from this promo here in the scene
where she's talking to vision messing with him
talking about being dead like she tells him
you're supposed to be dead but also in this
extra footage she also references the avengers
people are on the verge of discovering our secrets
so that means she actually knows kind of what's
going on so it just implies that she has a level
of authority inside this alternate reality
that some of the other characters might not
have but like monica rambo for instance we know
that she's a normal character from the main mcu
reality she's an agent of sword that's trying to
work with them to help figure out what's going on
with scarlet witch she probably also alters the
people's memories so they kind of forget who they
are or where they are or when they are like that's
what monica rambo is probably like i'm not totally
sure who i am a lot of you have also asked what
happened to scarlet witch's accent because she's
supposed to have a sokovian accent she's supposed
to be romani within the marvel cinematic universe
the reason why she doesn't have it in any of
this footage is because she's actually faking
this life she's pretending that she doesn't have
an accent it over time through the marvel movies
since she's been living with the avengers through
infinity war all the way through avengers end game
she just slowly became more and more americanized
culturally her english started getting better and
better and like she says during the trailer here
she wanted to fit in with the avengers so on the
show in a lot of these scenes the classic sitcoms
this is just the extreme example of that like she
says in the trailer footage i want us to fit in
so she's literally faking everything about this
reality like inevitably when we get to the finale
in this big battle that they're hyping up where
she tries to merge some aspects of this fake
reality the alternate reality with the main mcu
reality then she'll probably start speaking with
her accent a little bit again in the whole thing
with the extra episodes this is actually a really
big deal it's probably some of the best news that
we could get this early in january Wandavision
is now confirmed to be nine full episodes meaning
that the season finale episode nine will air
march 12th then the next week after that falcon
and winter soldier episode 1 starts march 19th so
there's no break in marvel content it'll be like
one new episode every week all the way pretty much
through june i think like what's happening is that
we'll have a marvel movie coming in may with black
widow but around then we'll also have the loki
series starting in may and that'll take us all the
way to shang chi in the legend of the 10 rings in
july so it sounds like marvel plans for there to
be one new piece of content either a new episode
or a new movie like a real big movie every single
week for at least the first half of the year
now there's a couple big star wars tv shows
that are going to be releasing later this year
like the bad batch episodes the star wars visions
episodes and then obviously the book of boba fett
mandalorian spin-off episodes in december so i
don't know if some weeks this year we're going
to get both of star wars new episode and a new
marvel episode of something but either way they're
coming for your money that's why they're trying to
keep releasing content every single week also as
part of that them coming for your money they just
announced their new adult quote-unquote content
section on disney plus for rated r content what's
happening is they're rolling this star section
out in the uk first it'll probably hit other
countries over the next year or so we have hulu
in the united states that's where all of disney's
adult content is going right now but eventually
they'll probably just fold the hulu stuff
into the disney plus app so you only have one
subscription you don't have to have two different
subscriptions to get all this different content
but all the biggest new marvel shows the star wars
shows that they're doing will always launch on the
core parts of the disney plus app they'll all
be pg-13 the only really big rated r movie that
marvel is going to be making in the next couple of
years will be deadpool 3 in any potential future
deadpool solo movies after that even though the
previous blade movies with wesley snipes were
are i believe the new blade movie with mahershala
ali is going to be pg-13 but we'll find out about
that pretty soon but for example the wesley snipes
blade movies would live in this rated r section of
disney plus either way it's just meant to simplify
the way that they release their content so instead
of having a bunch of different apps that you have
to have it'll just be one app what's happening
next though is this friday they're releasing
the marvel legends tv show that's meant to be an
intro to Wandavision sort of a prequel so to
speak i'll do episode videos for that i don't
know exactly what it's going to look like they've
been kind of quiet about it and speaking of extra
episodes if you remember the disney gallery
mandalorian episodes that they released like
the bonus content for all the mandalorian episodes
they're doing the same thing for the marvel series
but i don't know how many of those are going
to be released and when they'll release them
they haven't announced the schedule yet there's
a whole bunch of falcon and winter soldier stuff
that we've been learning about too but i'll
talk about that when i start doing more falcon
and winter soldier videos when we get a little bit
closer to that series they'll start releasing more
trailers for that while Wandavision is happening
but while you wait for everything click here for
my brand new fantastic four video and click
here to watch mark hamill reacting to luke
skywalker on the mandalorian thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!